قالت الاسيره الاسرائيليه المحرره حين
جولدشتاين ان عناصر حماس كانوا على
استعداد ان يموتوا في سبيل حمايه ارواح
الاسرى الاسرائيليين لدى الحركه في قطع
غزه كان هناك خوف من ان يتلقوا بعض
التعليمات وربما في النهايه سيقررون قتلنا
وكنا نسالهم ذلك احيانا ايضا فيقولون لنا
سوف نموت نحن قبل ان تموتوا اذا متنا
سنموت معا لاننا قريبون منكم ونحن
معكم وروت حين جولدشتاين كيف قام عناصر
حماس بحمايتهم خلال قصف اسرائيلي اصدف
الشارع القريب من مكان اقامه
الاس لقد كنا في سوبر ماركت نمنا ليله فيه
واحضروا اغطيه الى المخزن الذي كان خلف
السوبر ماركت وفي اليوم التالي حدث قصف
عنيف باتجاه الشارع القريب من السوبر
ماركت الذي تعرض الانفجار قوي وكانه صوت
المطرقه الكبيره لقد كان امرا مروعا وكان
الانفجار يقترب منا قمنا بالاحتماء
بالفراش وكان من اسرون من الارهابيين
يحمون باجسادهم يحمون باجسادهم وانتم
تحتهم يحمون من اطلاق النار من نيران
الجيش لقد كنا مهمين جدا بالنسبه
لهم